[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América con
Marta Moya Marta Buen día para usted
Feliz jueves Ángela Igualmente Marta y
vamos a comenzar Rescatando nuevamente
las portadas de los medios franceses que
recogen de manera casi unánime las
palabras del presidente de Manuel macron
en sus titulares en la entrevista que
concedió ayer a propósito de la Reforma
de las pensiones todo esto mientras hoy
avanza una novena jornada de huelga
contra esa misma reforma Así es Ángela
como decimos prensa monográfica
recogiendo esas palabras y esa
entrevista que ofreció ayer el
presidente de la república defendiendo
esa reforma pensional vamos a empezar
con la portada de liberación que titula
el gran atizador macron debería haber
calmado las aguas pero echó más leña al
fuego criticando a los sindicatos cuando
decíamos en paralelo se desarrolla la
novena jornada de protestas hemos
destacado también la portada de la qua
que titula continuar adelante con la
reforma Pero cómo macron se mostró
inflexible además en el editorial de la
crua choque de realidades sostiene y
recoge unas palabras de macron que decía
que hay una tendencia nuestra democracia
de querer abstenerse de la realidad y el
editorial de la croa dice el también se
abstrae de la realidad mirando hacia
otro lado frente a las protestas esos
dos tercios de los franceses que están
en contra de la reforma y que macron
Mira hacia otro lado por otro lado la
trivium titula este jueves cuestionado
sobre las pensiones macron distrae sobre
los beneficios extraordinarios de las
mismas hemos destacado también la
portada de léseco que titula este jueves
macron intenta recuperar el control pero
cosechó reacciones negativas tanto por
parte de los sindicatos como por parte
de los partidos opositores Y por último
le parisian titula reforma y método
macron a su método reformó la ley
pensional según el por obligación y no
por un deseo pues se ven bastante
implacables los medios franceses
definitivamente no se logró este
objetivo de calmar las protestas y las
granadas en las calles Bueno vamos a
seguir teniendo muchas más noticias de
esto a lo largo de la jornada Marta y
por eso quisiera que ahora cambiáramos
de tema y vayamos a Estados Unidos con
un reporte más bien preocupante el medio
usa today publica un reportaje que deja
datos que son demoledores sobre el
impacto de la violencia Armada contra
menores de edad en los hogares esto es
sorprendente Así es Ángela y el artículo
el reportaje del usaid today Dice que
dos tercios de los padres
estadounidenses temen que sus hijos sean
Víctimas de un tiroteo masivo en una
escuela sin embargo el peligro crece por
tres en el seno del hogar todo esto se
basa en datos de The trace que es una
ong que hace pedagogía sobre los
impactos de la violencia Armada en
Estados Unidos vamos a los datos entre
2018 y 2022
866 menores de 17 años fueron Víctimas
de disparos 621 de ellos murieron sin
embargo
268 Perdón recibieron tiros en las
escuelas sin embargo sólo 70 solo entre
comillas claro con muchos matices 75
fallecieron por tanto hablamos de que es
el triple de disparos y violencia que
termina con la con el fallecimiento de
los niños en el seno del hogar además
sostiene este artículo del usa today que
la mayoría de estos disparos fueron
intencionales y serán por parte de
padres padrastros o tutores en el primer
año de la pandemia además esta violencia
homicida contra menores se exacerbó en
2020 la violencia contra menores
violencia Armada creció un 61% respecto
a 2019 entre las causas que destaca el
usay today está el aumento de venta de
armas que en 2020 supuso 19 millones de
armas solo en los Estados o sea en
estadounidenses y además se suman las
tensiones familiares y los cierres de
negocios que pudieron causar un estrés
financiero y esto pues se deriva de una
situación potencialmente peligrosa En
aquellos hogares donde ya existen este
tipo de conductas abusivas para este
como para muchos otros fenómenos Marta y
yo siempre Insisto Hay que tener en
cuenta el componente de género y está
demostrado que aquí en este caso juega
un rol importante en estos desenlaces
violentos y en estas muertes trágicas
así es y lo destaca el reportaje del
usaid today que cuando O sea que a
menudo las víctimas jóvenes son Rehenes
de la violencia machista que se da en
los contextos del seno familiar
concretamente se destaca una cita
textual del reportaje que dice te voy a
matar o te voy a disparar es una amenaza
común que se hace para mantener el poder
no hay forma de retener a alguien que
controlar literalmente si vive O muere
si una mujer está siendo amenazada es
probablemente Es probable que sus hijos
estén en peligro destacamos la historia
de una abuela que se recoge en este
reportaje que dice que recibió una
videollamada de su nieta de 10 años
diciéndole que su mamá estaba muerta
tras la incredulidad la niña gira el
teléfono en esa videollamada y ve el
cuerpo de la madre no Y dice la abuela
literalmente ninguna madre abuela
bisabuela hermana o hermano debería
haber a su hijo tirado en un charco de
su propia sangre bueno Y aquí también
hay un tema veía algún caso Marta de
violencia vicaria no total parece que se
vengan de sus parejas una vez separados
a través de la muerte de sus hijos
rápidamente Australia parece que tras
más de 120 años las autoridades Quieren
reconocer a las poblaciones indígenas sí
Ángela esto es un artículo que destaca
el jazira fue una de las grandes
promesas de campaña que le llevaron a la
victoria al ahora Primer Ministro
Anthony alvanici en mayo de 2022 dice
que no se ha planteado antes no por una
voluntad sino porque las políticas se
hacen en canberra y no miran a las
comunidades el referendo para incluir a
los aborígenes e isleños del estrecho de
Torres se va a plantear entre octubre y
diciembre de este año ir estos suponen
el 3% de la población de una población
de más de 25 millones de habitantes Así
que un referente importante en un país
que quiere ser más inclusivo y una
victoria gracias a usted Marta gracias
Ángela